so many years ago they the diabolical
vay of Hollywood we're talking about
making his sequel to the movie twins and
I'm pretty sure it just happened twins
to Central Intelligence a on the point
to longer I'm just saying when you have
the biggest man in Hollywood and the
littlest men in Hollywood teaming up
together you're now gonna be compared to
twins
so Central Intelligence stars Dwayne
John's I'm trying not to call him the
rock because he doesn't call himself the
rock anymore so it's Dwayne Johnson and
Kevin Hart and in high school Kevin Hart
was super cool he was the master of
everything he was the homecoming king he
was super popular Dwayne Johnson's
character was not popular he was very
unpopular he got picked on he was fat
when the illustrate this at the
beginning of the movie it's a super hard
scene to watch but all right a couple
decades later now this dude becomes this
dude and this dude faces the exact same
so the rock and kevin hart meet up again
a call him the rock apparently they meet
up again and ultimately get wrapped up
in a spy action comedy because the rock
works for the CIA people are trying to
kill them people are trying to arrest
him Kevin Hartz caught in the middle of
it now you have another buddy cop movie
but it's not like cop cop it's CIA cops
totally different getting it out of the
way right now Kevin Hart and the rock
work really well together they're quite
awesome they have great chemistry you
can just tell they're having a lot of
fun filming together they have outtakes
at the end of the movie during the end
credits you can tell right there you're
like these two probably hang out Kevin
Hart totally has that Metro like oh I
can't leave mind me of like if
keegan-michael key went into the dryer
and came out like smaller and slightly
darker is that racist physically judge
Kevin Hart's just a darker man The
Rock's character I was on the razor's
edge with him for a little bit I was
like are you annoying or you'd like
really cool it's more on the lines of
annoying the dude is like a big kid and
like lose that party is like I started
to get bullied at the beginning of this
movies I'm glad you got past it but he's
still just recessed in his head he's
still just like a big child
he's very intrusive the dude is like a
hurricane coming into Kevin Hart's life
and you understand that Kevin Hart wants
no part of it and that may be the movies
being successful and what is trying to
do he can't help but kind of put on the
brakes for the rock your luck to pick up
and among some of the laughs in the
chemistry between Kevin Hart and the
rock ultimately you have a movie that
wants to be cooler than it is because
it's just kind of messy it's like
everything that happens
this movie is happening for the sake of
getting Kevin Hart and the rock into
some shenanigans again but one is what
movies like this do so you've seen a
hundred times before and - it's just
blatantly obvious priority one should be
having a great movie and then building
everything around that like everything
that works in this movies because I have
a soft spot for people who get bullied
and I like to see them overcome the
bullies and that whole element of it is
great you want to see the kid who got
bullied in high school become the rock
and now you do and you're like oh dude
that's awesome you totally got past it
but he still has his issues because like
I said he's just is almost is an
obnoxious manchild but that really only
carries a movie like this so far before
you're like alright I'm kind of past it
I want to see a good movie I want to
enjoy myself a little more guys in the
end central intelligence you can see the
trailer and you know exactly the kind of
movie it's gonna bei to have your laugh
you have some great chemistry between
Kevin Hart in the rock it really does
feel like a friendship of sorts but
sometimes the movie was a bit annoying
for a few different reasons throughout
the movie whether it be the messy plot
it's also a cliched plot to the
predictability of the plot to the
overall aimlessness of the plot that
ultimately serves as a runway for Kevin
Hart and the rock to just do [ __ ] I'll
say Central Intelligence has some laughs
but in the end it would be a better time
if you're drunk ya know it's a party
remember good time if you're drunk
doesn't mean unenjoyable let's enjoy MIT
in here paying full price and for your
listening pleasure this video is brought
to you by audible I'm laughing because
it's almost like every youtuber hits
their sponsorship all at the same time
so you guys get blasted with it it
cracks me up there's a link below to
audible.com slash John's you can get
yourself a free 30-day trial of audible
like two hundred and fifty thousand
audiobooks in their libraries it's
exponentially growing getting insane
listen to some origins Neil deGrasse
time on a big Neil deGrasse Tyson kick
when it comes to audiobooks I like
listening to science like it's an
electrical or something like that
there's just how I roll that's that's
how I do most importantly thanks for
watching I love you all all right guys
so Central Intelligence have you seen it
what did you think about it what's your
favorite buddy comedy cop or otherwise
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more